Russian scientists have found an asteroid the size of a mountain...
...that supposedly crosses the Earth's orbit every three years.
So that plus a lot of time means...
I know this stuff could be heavy,...
...but at least you got to see a watermelon blow up.
As of right now, the rock called "2014 UR116" is not coming right for us,...
...and we're not sure if it would ever actually hit us.
But its discovery is a surprise!
The Russian scientists explained it's really difficult to track these types of objects...
...since we're not sure how their routes will be affected...
...by the gravity of the other planets in our system.
And we're discovering objects, not always this big, every day.